[Applause]
thank you so much for coming well thanks
for having me i uh i love this movie
magnolia it's and not just me
everybody's talking about this film
that's what they say
yeah they say nice things about it it's
uh it it defies description a little bit
so i'm not gonna i don't think we should
get into trying to explain okay i think
people should go see this movie numerous
times yep
ten times
at least uh performances are great and i
wanted to start off by saying i think
the the first movie that you did that
really caught my attention was boogie
nights yeah yeah and i could tell when
you see the movie that here's someone
you didn't just sort of go at the
surface of the
porn industry it felt like you
understood this industry
how did you how did you get interested
in the subject of porn and if that's not
a stupid question
what is
um
like any young boy you know
i just you read about porn in history
books
i grew up in the san fernando valley
which is the capital of porn production
and that's not that's not what san
fernando calls it yeah um it's not on
their license plate
um and i where i went to high school
there's like a lot of warehouses you
know and they all had signage except
you'd get to one and it would have no
signage and like really fancy cars
parked out front and
if you're completely perverted you just
think there's porno in there
and that's the way you'd say it too
there's porno in here i can just tell
there's porno
uh now uh
one of the scenes that of course
everyone talks about in that movie is uh
where uh
where marky mark what do you call him
mark wahlberg i call him marky marcus
but i'm i was his boss so i can call him
marquis you could call him stinky
but in that movie uh at one point he is
please tell me it's a prosthetic penis
i've heard it is yeah okay good uh
this giant penis and then i've heard
that that that uh it got lost or that
somebody else has no no well mark you
probably told you that because he still
has it he i know for i know for a fact i
went over to his house and i and i said
do you still have it and he said yeah
and he pulled out this plastic bag like
ziploc baggie right you know and it
there there it is but but that's where
you'd keep it
i was like you know but those things
they don't last for they start to
disintegrate you know it's plastic the
fake ones
[Laughter]
no but it's it's it's marky has it so
okay yeah all right i've had to get you
know lauren beatty actually called me
the other day
and was asking for it where is it yeah i
want that damn thing he did yeah
everyone's looking for it
like we all need a little help no no all
right
gotta move this thing along come on this
is we're offending people at three
o'clock in the morning in houston uh
let's talk about now magnolia these are
amazing performances and there's there's
uh
there's not one there's not one bad or
flawed performance in this whole thing
like i would know but uh it seemed great
to me tom cruise of course got this
golden globe yeah and he plays it's a
fascinating character he plays a
sort of tell us it's actually based on
real life guys who do this they teach
courses on how to seduce women and uh
they they have some of the most insane
techniques that you you
you can't imagine that it's something
that really happens but these guys teach
sort of empowerment courses to men on
how to manage how they can go out there
and get a woman and and and yeah get
that naughty sauce is how the way tom
describes it in the movie not necessary
to bring that up
now now uh
one of one of the things
one of the things that i really one of
the things that that fascinated me about
this is that before the movie came out
you actually made an ad with tom cruise
and you put it into late night tv across
the country this is sort of our
equivalent of the infomercial that you
had made right sort of tom's character
in the movie does make infomercials so
sort of one of the ideas was on my own i
bought late night television time slots
and you can gobble it up for like 200
you can get like a six-hour chunk so
i don't know what they're doing you know
i mean
yeah
after 12 30. it's pretty much a
wasteland isn't it to you paul it really
is
i mean film lasts forever
yeah this crap i i mean i i just paid
for it myself yeah right you put it on
your amex yeah uh but we did we did it
was uh i i it was sort of an you know i
don't know this is a cool idea because
people seeing it didn't know they're
they're just seeing this ad with tom
cruise it's kind of amazing because it
did it did i stayed up one night to
watch it and and and at a certain point
you're so tired you're just sort of
vaguely watching tv and there's sort of
the golf
commercial like a new golf grip and then
tom cruise and then you know like a
lawnmower commercial and i was
just it doesn't make sense it freaks
people out well let's and people thought
this was real let's show the ad and then
talk about the reaction take a look at
this ad that they really ran with uh tom
cruise in it
i don't care how you look i don't care
what car you drive i don't care what
your last bank statement says seduce and
destroy produces an instant money-back
guaranteed trance-like state that will
get you this
naughty sauce you want
fast
he's good at that yeah
the uh
so what were
were people calling i mean people were
calling the number is that right yeah
what kind of comments were you getting
from people who called the number well
uh uh uh it was a scary combination of
of guys who were wanting to order it
which made me a little bit nervous about
continuing to run it but i can explain
my call by the way
but then there was this there's this one
guy who called up who was really upset
who thought it was like sort of a direct
line to tom cruise just saying man
you're a sellout man you know you
probably you probably you probably got
like ten thousand dollars for that and
that's just that's that's screwed up man
you know i liked you before but now no
i'm over you so i thought that was very
funny kind of interesting now the
critics of uniformly they they really
love this movie magnolia
they're it can't be for everybody there
got to be some people who maybe it's too
unusual for them what what kind of
response you get from them how can you
tell if someone just couldn't get into
it for whatever reason
they generally just start talking about
boogie nights you know they switch over
yeah they're like
oh hey man good to see you do you
remember that scene in boogie nights
when i you know and i'll i'll just sort
of instantly know yeah well i don't
think you'd be getting that very much
because as i've said it's it's just a
fascinatingly original it's a great
movie and uh go out and see this film
and no one listens to me so don't feel
good about this but uh magnolia is in
theaters now and uh paul thomas anderson
best of luck to you thank you very much
phenomenally talented guy paul thomas
anderson
will uh take a little break when we come
back jack ingram gonna be here so stick
around